Bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk,
bonk, bonk.
Bonk, bonk, bonk.
Hello.
Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'm sorry, my voice is a little dead today.
I'm sorry.
I overworked it.
Because I was out having too much fun.
I was out having too much...
It's not sick.
It's just me being like, Woo, woo, woo!
Veg voice, yes.
Didn't enjoy my lunch, I did.
I got some yummy noodles and some ice cream.
And I was so sleepy coming back.
I took an app.
About...
Uh...
Like 20 minutes ago.
So sorry if I sound a little funky.
And if I'm sleepy.
Maybe I should have gotten coffee.
But yeah, we're here for Mega Ball.
Come on, thank you.
Hello, Vito, and I have booze like you.
I hope your trip has been awesome so far.
I had some fun with your friends and lunch.
I did.
Thank you.
Hello.
Nice meeting you and the rest of Dents as well.
We've got Vito.
Thanks for coming to see us.
I did do that on Sunday.
Sunday.
Had a little bit of a meet and greet.
And I got to meet some other people.
And see some old friends.
Or not friends.
Old faces.
I did see some friends too.
Oh, to dance so.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Old Enemies!
Oh my gosh, Mikiro!
Thank you so much!
Seeing you work, there's also the bonus here got me
motivated too.
No!
Don't do that!
I have no bones to work to!
I returned to finishing a degree and got a promotion!
And thanks, as thanks, here's my first akka with first check
on my birthday!
Vecchio
Congratulations And happy birthday Sorry my voice must sound
so bad It doesn't hurt It's just that it's I'm a little
squeaky today Squeak, squeak, squeak
Vecchio Thank you Oh my gosh Congratulations, and thank you,
and congratulations, and thank you.
Minky bonk.
Minky mouse.
Yeah.
Who is the place that everybody wants to go and see?
M-I-N-K-I-M-O-U-S-E.
M-I-K-M-O-S-E.
Wait, M-I-N-K-I-M-O-U-S-E.
Minky Mouse.
I kindly offer until you $10 is an excuse to tell you that I
finally passed my kidney stone.
Casey!
Congratulations.
Holy cow.
Everybody's giving me your life updates.
It's been a couple days since I've been able to talk with
many people.
I just barely missed the cutoff for the meet-and-greet of
Weebcon.
Oh!
And you had a great set of Oshibar.
Thank you!
Other iBus are also so friendly in person.
I know, I know.
You guys are so nice.
Thank you.
Life update, I missed Minto.
I'm right here!
Other iBus are so chill with this wave.
yeah there were people giving away freak freak phantom
glasses and I hope I hope every time there's an event
everybody I always like seeing everybody gather I want to
see I always want to see more eyeball gatherings you know I
want to see more eyeball gatherings and and everybody
Everybody just hanging out, having a good time.
Even though I get a little FOMO.
I'm like, oh, that looks so fun.
Everybody's hanging out.
Wow.
What would you call an Aibu gathering?
An Aibu gathering?
Dilaran, thank you.
I'm starting a new job tomorrow.
Good luck.
Look!
It's a great thing all of you did too too.
We've gone to concert with everybody.
I'm happy.
My wife could show up for death.
She looks stunning.
Stunning.
I love their jersey too.
Thank you so much.
My sister is pregnant.
Congratulations to your sister.
Ibu Congregation.
That's pretty good.
Congregution.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys for all the super chats.
What is happening?
Is it because...
Wait, did you guys have a good Easter?
Don't die!
We're so good seeing you again.
Yeah, happy birthday.
I'm glad you had so much fun that you became the squeakster
again.
I'll be fine as soon as I'm back, you know.
Fan baby belated birthday!
Sorry I missed it yesterday.
Oh, I know you like theme park stuff, but when I ask if
there was a theme park, theme ride after you.
Wait, a ride themed after me.
What kind of a ride would it be?
A roller coaster with many, many drops.
big drop big drop high speed action and it would be themed
oh wait you said it would be themed after me it would be it
would be it would have like like a story it would be
atmospheric hanging out with the hypos is great they're all
very kind and welcoming murphy give me a little buying, I
will treasure her forever.
I'm glad.
Looking forward to seeing a bunch of Aibu in two weeks after
I see someone else's...
Someone's birthday, Seitan.
Yeah, everybody hang out!
Seitan, Seitan.
I don't have anything to say.
I just want to be part of the group.
Oh, no.
Thank you.
Mito, please keep bonking internet.
Wait, is my internet bad?
Am I cutting out?
Thank goodness it's Monday.
no the coaster carts will look like cardboard boxes have you
guys seen the the the DK ride at Universal DK I want to go I
want to go on it because it's like kind of themed it looks
so fine I did see the Minecraft E-Bark You guys, there's a
Minecraft theme park that's going to be opening in London.
Now I have to go.
I have to go.
I like that.
To go to the Minecraft.
They, they, they, it's Enderman.
Enderman.
Mickey cute tags.
Yo, yo, yo.
I think what happened is we missed Jimmy Dawson.
so I can finally make.
Oh, God, he's here!
I'm nervous.
I'm nervous, too.
What you have to do is...
You have to come see me.
Make Limes take you?
Wait, that's so true.
As a UK-based Ibu, can I ask, do you have any UK-based con
appearances coming up?
You don't have to share the deeds of their secret.
Just a yes or no would be fine.
Phil?
I don't know.
Actually, tentative...
Yes.
Tentative Yes OMG at Domingue
No leaks
European tour It's not up to me It's up to Places to invite
me If I don't get invited I can't go You know what I mean?
That's the goal Yeah!
Did you see the Mario movie?
No.
But I heard Rosalina is only in it for 10 minutes.
So I'm kind of reconsidering if we...
I'm reconsidering if I go see it or not.
Was it good?
Had a nice Easter long weekend.
Did you have a chance to get some Easter chocolate?
I didn't see a single bunny.
No eggs either.
I did hear that.
Some people say that this Mario movie was better than the
first one.
Thank you for showing me Rat Claiming, though.
Of course.
It was a good movie, Bit Rush, though.
No!
I heard mixed things about it.
Ha.
I don't know.
I heard Fox stole the movie.
Where is he?
Which of you are today?
Yes.
Why would you ask me that?
Why is Fox in the movie, though?
You think they're going to be making a new Star Fox game?
The music had me tearing up.
I think I will tear up hearing Chris Pratt's voice.
He just ruins my day.
They supposedly are.
As much as I want to go to an eyeball gathering, I get very
nervous.
My anxiety spikes like ramp prices.
Also, the Easter Bunny overcharged mech for chocolate.
No!
Honestly, I get that.
I understand completely.
Like, you know, meeting new people, going to a place that,
you know, going outside of your comfort zone, it can be
really anxiety-inducing.
I get even, I get nervous So often Even like going to meet
an idol That I've met a hundred times I get nervous, I'm
like Oh my gosh But I think Aibu especially Are so
Everybody's so Goofy and silly and fine and welcoming And
kind That if you're nervous You know If you're ever wanting
to Obviously I'm never gonna say like force yourself, but if
you are if you are like, you know what, maybe I will take a
chance
then an Ibu gathering would be the perfect place.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for making it to WeebCon me too.
That was the last one.
So I sort of rambled.
Oh!
But you made a whole con and congrats to the concert.
We're all so proud of you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Actually, I have some work after this to do for the concert.
Hmm.
Whatever could it be, whatever could it be.
And then tomorrow, I have some stuff to do for the concert
as well.
So, once I boo, twice shy.
It's okay.
We're shy too.
Once I boo, but twice shy.
songs in july for easter i forgot it was easter slept in and
went to see project hail mary it was great i only realized
it was easter from bunny suit fan art more bunny suit fan
art please it's april oh
yeah but then there's like people say people say Christmas
in July why did they say that why what is where where did
this come from chronotrix welcome back thank you I thought
the whole point of the vacation was to give yourself a break
oh well I mean I had a couple days off and then I'm gonna
have I'm gonna stream today and tomorrow and then I'm going
to have a couple more days off.
So that's a break.
Is it because halfway to Christmas?
Oh, anyway.
I can't stop me aligning.
Maybe I need to bonk some things to wake myself up.
I need to bonk to wake up.
Shall we bonk?
It's been a minute since I last played this game.
But...
Do it.
I can't show you any.
I can't show you what I have.
I kind of want to eat my Del Taco.
Have you guys ever had Del Taco before?
Do you guys like...
Are you a Taco Bell or are you a Del Taco?
Coffee Fines, thank you.
Yes.
good?
I think it's good.
Neither?
Taco Bell for live.
Baja Blast keeps me in Taco Bell.
Okay, but please consider the Del Taco Lemonade.
Del Taco Lemonade has
strawberries at the bottom.
Glad to see you get that way to ask a question later on
during the stream so watch out for that you don't have to
answer if you don't want to oh oh wait why later wait why
later thank you for the super chat okay the crunch wrap is
so good though we don't have a del taco where i'm from no he
needs to pick up the ring from the jeweler first quiet now
I'm not going to see what we've got this weekend.
Sorry, it was a sandwich at the time.
It was so funny.
Because I was just watching that guy.
I was watching Reese.
Shout out to Reese.
I was watching Reese carry the standy through the line of
solemn arms up in the air like a man don't care.
It was so funny.
Like there he is.
They are solemn.
Hi, hi, chat.
Hello, hello.
Reese, my guy.
Da lifter.
It was so funny.
Yeah, you were a little quiet, though.
Are you nervous?
Were you nervous?
Oh, my gosh.
Don't be nervous around me.
be nervous around me it's silly we have a del taco but
locally it's 20 miles away i just have taco bell so don't
know about del taco bell you know that's fine if you ever go
to california try the del taco how many marriage proposals
did you get this time none it was it was all of den set to
It was all three of us.
Sometimes a guy gets a little shy.
Who are peeing?
All three.
Shoot your shot for all three of us.
I dare you.
It was fun, though.
It was my first time doing like a meet and greet.
with more than one person like obviously it's just me
talking to people but this time it was all three of us so um
it was really fine meet some obakas as well and phoebe hive
and i love me and gory i love them so much they're so fine
it's great seeing our weep con i was the one who did your
sound check oh thank you thank you thanks for the hell.
I love chatting with the girls.
It was fun because like after, like in between people or
like, yeah, in between people we would be able to be like we
would talk with each other too.
So it's not just me waiting on the next person.
Like we would be like, oh my gosh, that person saying that
was so funny or something like that.
Girl talk.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Did Steiner try and steal the spotlight?
Not this time.
He was there, though, unfortunately.
So we might do another three-group person meet and greet in
the future like that.
Unfortunately.
Matara would not stop sending me photos of Steiner.
And I'm like, please, please stop ruining my day.
I don't need to know what this guy is up to.
But Matara was there in person.
A flesh.
Crazy.
Steiner watch.
I think I need to stop talking about him.
Or else people will keep sending me stuff about him.
get her own manager so true he told me a story though yeah
hold on let me get let me get this let me pull this up
he was like
he said um okay i'm just gonna read this what he told me he
said our uber to the restaurant took too long due to crap no
no due to traffic congestion so So Matara eyed up a
cosplayer getting out of a car, walked over and was like,
did you ride here with friends or family or was that an
Uber?
And the poor girl was like, uh, uh, that was my brother.
To which Matta followed up with, okay, you're going to take
me to the car and roll down the window.
Then I'm going to offer your brother $60 to drive me and my
friend here to a restaurant, okay?
And then we kind of hijacked this friend of Suber's car.
And so, I tweeted, at Matara Khan, what the hell is wrong
with you?
Because it's the most insane extrovert energy I think I've
ever heard of ever in the world.
Wish I could go to a Vita Me Too in the eyeballs, but I
gotta get another job before that.
So please, a Vita from me too.
X-ray, you got the letters.
Pure confidence.
It's kind of insane.
It's just insane.
I throw up.
I know.
It's kind of wild.
We were joking about Snyder and Vatara going on a date.
Ow.
I got actual shivers.
He had like.
It was like a.
it was like a like a they had some stuff that they actually
needed to discuss but
yeah i'm gonna throw up for real that's like that's like mom
and dad kissing you know and you're like oh no please
okay do you pretend he's santa
she's a word he'd come in like i don't even like not even
knock he would just like kick down the door the worst she
could say is no minto thinking about matara and stiders i'm
not even gonna finish that You guys are giving me mental
damage, please!
Please, spare my brain.
Let's bonk.
Let's bonk out these thoughts, right?
We have a couple things that I can do here.
I can... I want to use the cheese.
I want to use the moldy cheese.
We're gonna, we're gonna use the cheese.
Play 30 quests.
Kill 15,000 goblins.
Did I unlock?
I think I unlocked Mega Chad.
Oh my god, his powers.
He wields the perfect, most powerful jawline.
Oh, yeah.
His aura damages enemies in the area around you.
Flex has stopped.
Okay, wait.
How do I play this game again?
It's a must.
Don't keep.
Oh, don't say that either.
Well, many things have happened.
Like this past week.
Many things.
He's an S-tier character.
He flexes and they die.
Oh, yeah, he does.
Flex to stop damage.
Skin.
Let's try him.
Teleport to the second stage on Forest Tier 2 as Clank.
Oh.
we'll do we'll do tier one just to get me back into the uh
the game of it you know let's try huge jack-to-miron all
right let me get back into it can I how's the audio by the
way guys oh wow Audio's good?
It's not too loud?
That's good.
Okay.
I am gonna turn it down actually like a tad for me.
Like that.
Okay.
Sorry.
For my own...
Can I turn it down?
Wait.
Wait, that's Wi-Fi.
This is the...
Okay, good.
If I turn it down for me, it doesn't turn it down for you.
Sorry, you heard that.
Don't turn down the Wi-Fi.
What are we going to get?
Bone!
Bone?
Windows 11 sucks.
This is Windows 10.
The Wi-Fi is too loud.
Miko, we need you to...
Quiet.
Bone.
Does each character have their own song?
This is great.
Hit that guy.
Oh my god, he's just really...
Okay, so we have to find some stuff, right?
Some of them.
Sturdy gold.
That's all I got.
Holy cow!
He!
He's so strong!
Um.
Alright.
For the sake of me getting back into the game, I'm allowing
you guys to help me with my choices.
Usually I let you anyway, but...
The aura.
Wait, we already have aura.
What if we keep our aura?
One for more projectiles.
True.
You're so right.
Gym sauce.
For our king.
Oh my gosh.
We're already, okay.
No help.
No, please.
I need the help.
I'm thinking a damage tome.
Or the size?
Our aura would get bigger.
Size, right?
Size would be crazy.
Yeah.
Is it...
I can't remember.
Is gold important in the beginning?
It's all about the size for chains.
Gold is long term.
It does let us open more chests.
And get good upgrades, right?
If we find the shady guy.
Yeah, you need it to buy items.
But then damage.
Golden crit.
Oh, crit, yeah.
We'll do gold then.
Look at this.
He like, what's a greed?
Oh, wait, that makes it harder.
I don't remember.
I almost touched it.
Evasion.
I will be a little slippery, slopey, slip, slip, slip.
Size.
Bigger.
Hmm.
We shall do more crit.
We will be stronger.
I do think I want to get a damage eventually, but...
Oh.
What a big aura from you.
Oh, thank you.
We'll do more bone.
Hmm.
Get the XP tone.
We could try.
Oh, I guess I should have gotten it, huh?
Some shield.
Oh, shield would be good.
Shield is always good.
You're right.
Yes, yes.
Having a little...
Oh.
Golden Skelly!
No!
Oh, nice.
Medkit!
Yes, very good.
150.
Dang!
We like kill these guys so fast.
This is actually insane.
Uh-oh, wait.
Always break parts.
Agility, movement speed.
skip or refresh we'll refresh I guess aura huh what's a
different oh skip skip would be oh I got braided oh thank
you see none thank you so much nice thank you thank you so
much for the raid Thank you so much for the gifted.
Paperbacks, thank you for the gifted.
Hello.
I'm playing Mega Bonk.
I'm on vacation.
But I wanted to stream a little bit while I was gone.
Three.
Wait, really?
More movement speed?
Door go.
Thank you so much.
I'm thinking the crit damage, no?
Move speed is good.
See, see, thank you.
All right.
I'll do movement speed since you guys are telling me so.
Let's see what we got going on around here.
I feel like my sensitivity for my mouse could go up a little
bit more.
We gotta go find the thing.
The final boss thing.
What is duration?
Duration of your attacks and projectiles.
Two.
Attack speed?
You guys are king today.
Oh.
What do I have right now?
Oh, our bone is an uncommon.
Ranch.
Oh, okay.
How's this?
Good!
Uh-oh.
Chungus.
Chunk him.
Oh,
shoot.
Ouch!
What are you?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
ouch, ouch.
Bacon, charging the charge run will turn into a healing
zone!
Also spawn plus two extra charge shines.
Ooh!
Wait, did I charge this one?
Oh, I do.
But there's one down here.
Would knockback be good?
More aura?
Okay.
More, more aura!
And we will charge this one.
Yes.
Knockback is okay, not great.
We were, yeah.
Aura farm.
I've never aura farmed before in my afterlife.
This is so exciting.
This is a first for me.
Oh, this one's uncommon.
Egy.
This is a first for me.
Oh my gosh guys, first time aura farming, but please be,
please be kind.
I really gotta go find the thing though, don't I?
Luck?
Maybe luck?
You can check the map.
How do I do that again?
I think luck is good.
No, no, no, don't leave, don't leave.
Aura.
Swarming coming.
Right, well.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Uncommon.
Oh, wait, the size, though.
But we'll still go up in size.
Map is tabbed.
Thank you so much.
Oh, ow.
Wait, I see it.
I see the winds.
They're blowing.
This is it.
I found it.
Okay.
Sigh!
Oh.
Oh no.
Sighs would be good, no.
More oral.
More size.
I just don't want them to even get close to me.
My...
You cannot handle my oral traveler.
Spawn boss in the last minute or two.
Okay, thank you.
Cool down?
One.
The people have spoken.
Thank you guys for helping.
Helping me.
Wait.
Oh!
Maybe bone?
Well, how do you have 3.4 projectiles?
Two, me lord?
Okay, I actually see a lot of people saying two.
All right.
Pick number two, me lord.
I thought I had...
Projectile bounces.
So it'll like use more than...
Look how big our aura is.
Actually, it's kind of insane.
Alright, so we found the...
Okay, rare aura!
We're like a good thing that gives me all my coins.
Like sucks them up for me, you know?
My rare aura.
The way he walks is too cool.
I should go with the aura, right?
With the cooldown.
Oh.
More aura.
One?
I think I got We gotta go for the aura.
We'll go for cooldown if we get the next.
I'm gonna beat it.
Crazy.
Look at this.
It like...
It like tilts upwards when I'm...
Where does this pot do in here?
That's so silly.
Let's go get some more upward.
Down, down,
down, down, down, down, down, down.
A border!
Oh, I already got these.
What is this right here?
Stonks!
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, gosh, that's fast.
Another rare aura!
Guys.
How is...
How?
Evasion.
Oh, it's these guys.
Destroy, destroy, destroy.
No, don't go at the wall.
Don't go at the wall.
Don't go at the wall!
Wait, don't leave!
We'll do the cooldown.
Alright, we got three minutes.
Why does it feel like the map is so small?
This is just me.
I think I missed him.
I don't even worry.
Wait, how do I block?
There's nothing.
They're just chests for no reason.
Because my aura is too big.
Freaking them out a little bit.
Ouch!
A biggie.
Wait, what's this do?
Get the parts.
I think I want to do bone.
One?
Cool down.
Really?
Okay.
I'm trusting you guys with my whole in-game life.
What's this?
Oh, nice!
That's what I was hoping for!
Free chest back there.
Oh, I missed it?
Thank you.
more cool down oh I'm gonna keep going with the cool down oh
I'm they show
on the map too okay thank you let's go with the aura wait
isn't there like a way to skate down the thing
we'll do more damage oh my gosh
control thank you and here a big a chunk of monster drop the
chest.
Okay, thank you.
Yeah, let's go aside.
Cool down rare.
Plus 8x begin.
Cool.
Alright.
Dang, we got a lot from that.
I see some more.
Where?
Oh, that guy is born right in front of me.
it's fine he's in my aura he's going down nice oh i heard
the kachonk
noise oh we're going this way no my golden skelly he's going
off the bigger and better places oh yeah time for the portal
let's go to do that let's go do they?
Thorns.
That's like a, if they touch me, it does damage, right, to
them?
Yeah, they'll damage.
Um, talk to the shady guy.
I think maybe shield.
No, we'll do our max.
Oh, yeah, here he is.
Hello.
What do we want?
Wait, these are all lame.
Wait, these are also lame.
I'll still buy it.
Yeah.
Oh, oops.
I didn't mean to open that actually.
Ha ha ha.
Costa.
Alright.
Oh.
I will do bone.
To the portal!
Rip Malai.
Oh no, wait, I didn't see him.
Oh, where's he going?
Why are you going up?
Oh.
This is kind of goofy looking.
Kind of goofy looking.
I feel like I'm not doing anything.
I don't care.
Woo!
Let's sing on the haters.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Wait.
We only have like 16 seconds left.
Whoa!
I went for the burger.
I'm a hungry man.
i'm sorry ouch
i'm too hungry ouch okay you got this we'll leave until
final swarm let's do
hey aminto hello let's do two he's almost dead he's almost
dead oh shoot
Why not?
Bigger.
Bigger, bigger.
Orra.
The moldy cheese.
This is what I wanted.
Wait, I wonder if we can actually kill anything with it.
Unfortunately, we don't get to go...
We don't get to go to the next area.
Because it's on easy mode.
Clover.
Oh, that would have been great earlier.
on.
Thanks for nothing.
Shield, shield, shield, shield, shield.
Extra shield, more shield.
Do this deck?
I don't know.
You'll be able to unlock the... I think I had the tier.
Oh, that guy was coming for me.
Oh, he's coming for me.
Oh, they really start...
Oh, my gosh.
They really start coming.
Oh my god, they really start coming.
Holy cow.
We'll just keep doing the orb.
Ghost on Ghost of Islands.
Ouch!
I'm stuck.
No.
I don't like seeing him like this.
Actually, it looks like he's just walking.
He's having a pleasant day.
I'm walking here.
Even in death, he was mocking us, for real.
I'm so much.
That was a great run, I think.
That was a really good run, I think.
Top 50k.
What do you guys think?
Run.
What else we got?
Quantity Tome.
Battery.
Are there any things that I should buy?
How much silver do I have, actually?
Doesn't say.
Oh, I have 44.
Just kidding.
Spooky.
Quantity is great.
Actually, bloody Tome.
Armor Tome.
Should do weapons.
Oh, I only have a couple.
Ayyush.
Congrats to the 46,583rd Best Mega Bunker!
Thank you, Gappa.
I hold that title with such pride.
Oh, we have more items, too.
Wait, oh, I was already looking at these.
The key.
The key!
Wait, I need the key to unlock the thing.
There are still more tomes.
I'm curious what the bloody tomes.
Lifesteal.
Forbidden juice.
Let's try the key.
I'm so curious about it.
Oh, wait.
Templar resent.
Wait.
This is not the key I was thinking of.
Hmm.
Let's open the chest for free.
10% chance.
That sounds great.
The monkey cage is...
It's a monkey?
Let's go back for Chad.
Yeah, that's my bad.
Tier 2.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
I'm nervous.
What was this?
Wait.
Wait, it already.
What's that?
Rage!
How long am I raging for?
Axe!
Throw spinning axes at deal area damage.
We just bought this one.
Flicks on the minky.
I'm flexion.
Axe is fun.
Shall we try?
Axe in size would be nice.
Let's try the axe.
Oh wow.
Oh wow, these are nice and fast.
Oh, and they're gone.
Well, they only appear when somebody's in range.
That's kind of nice.
Oh, sorry.
I'm trying to get this bot.
Ow, I'm flexing.
I'm flexing on the haters.
You can't handle me.
Wait, XP would be kind of good right now, though, wouldn't
it?
Like early on?
Early XP.
Okay, I'm glad I had the same thought process.
XP is meta.
I'm thinking with portals, I'm thinking with portals.
Oh!
Extra jump.
Why?
One will save you.
Oh, really?
Uh oh, wait.
Is that on my shelf?
Increase luck.
But also increase the chest prize.
Extra jump is so nice in another area.
Oh, maybe I'm not there yet.
The bloody tomb!
Is it?
I mean, lifesteal seems pretty great, no?
Bloody is weak.
Okay.
Pushy open up.
Ouch.
I could use some lifesteal right now.
Actually, the way that goes with my...
my XP thumb.
Lifesteal is one of the best perks in the game, especially
once it levels up.
Really?
Rip weak build.
Why am I weak?
XP early.
Yeah, XP early.
Power up multiplier.
Increases the power of power ups effect and duration.
Wait, like all of them?
Does that mean items and tomes?
Only power.
Oh, those.
Okay.
Yeah, like the stuff like stop time.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
I'll go with the crit though.
I wish I could get more...
No!
Wait.
Oh, ouch.
There he is.
No, no, no, no, don't let him leave!
Don't let him leave!
Oh!
I'm dying!
Oh, I died.
Wait, that was pretty bad.
My bad.
Wait, that was kind of terrible.
I did.
Agreed.
Let's try that again.
run don't worry about it everybody everything will happen
the same exact way except i won't die trust oh what do you
have what do you have mr man you got some mittens standing
still heals you charge shrine okay okay i may be back for
your wares i'm hitting them and you clap their cheeks
generates a lightning strike.
That sounds a little bit.
Oh, but now.
But now, all right.
Summon the challenge.
Not right now.
I just started game, please.
Give me a moment.
Is that right now?
Wait, another shady guy.
I'm gonna do the bloody.
Bob!
Okay, maybe we save up for him.
Let's go down here.
Oh yeah, there is fall damage now, isn't there?
Fine, I flexed it off.
I'm too powerful.
Yay!
Thank you!
Fuzzy, thank you so much for the whole month!
Thank you so much!
I'm gonna do the armor.
Sounds like an easy choice.
Holy cow, those guys are nice.
Projectile count!
Oh wait, this is so hard to choose!
Quantity.
This is so good?
Okay.
We're getting quantity, everybody.
more bananas we're going banana crazy as i always say i want
to go banana i always say that that's literally like my i've
said that since day one it's my catchphrase ouch ouch say i
want to go banana crazy oh banana rye monkey build i
remember that yeah i was literally in my debut
We'll go with the we'll go with the two just because it's
uncommon Oh, wait Would duration be better gold gang gold
gold gang gold game two Cowabunga moment
I do feel I need more gold Moe moe boo haunted bakery is my
nickname.
I'm going banana crazy.
All of these.
One or two.
We'll go to them.
More gold.
You guys are the greeds.
I feel strange not having like a huge aura right now though,
you know what I mean?
It's kind of weird.
It feels wrong.
Oh, okay.
Oh, moldy cheese!
Oh, a chest dropped.
My bad.
Thank you so much.
Always feel free to yell at me about chest drop.
Qua- Aura.
I'm gonna go with the aura this time.
We'll go with quantity next time.
There are!
Wait, who's that?
What is this?
Oh, this is the summoner I don't want a challenge.
I want to live an easy, nice life as a Chad.
And everyone keeps getting in my way.
Challenge gets you a chest.
Does it?
Let's see.
Oh, oh jeez.
Oh jeez.
Oh, jeez.
I'm like slipping and sliding here though, guys.
Not so great.
Oh, rare quantity!
My aura is weak, you're right.
I do need a better aura.
I'm doing good?
Thanks!
One, get more life steal.
But more... more banana.
what if I get more banana oh my god there's so many bananas
oh no a chunk is okay we absolutely we mugged okay wait am I
using am I using a mug right
he got
porked where's this uh the guy that where's the mr shady man
oh rare orba
boomer spotted oh guys if you want to use if you want uh
gamer subs please use code boomer what the what just
happened oh the extra jumps didn't you guys say that was
good Thank you so much, brother!
Where's the brain?
Hello!
You hogged them.
Oh, just kidding.
What is it do?
There we go.
I'm jumping.
Thank you, thank you for the gifted!
More size!
Wait, am I lost?
Maybe a little bit.
Oh, here's a shady guy.
Swarm is incoming.
Excuse me.
Dargo, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Yeah, thank you!
Incognito, cats, thank you!
Thank you, no, thank you!
Thank you guys so much for the gifted!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Gifted, so the...
More XP?
XP maxing?
That's fair.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Quantity.
Oh, ouch, ouch!
I need a burger!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, bloody tone.
Size.
You're doing great!
I've never played this before.
Thank you for your encouragement.
Very much.
Thank you.
Let me go, thank you!
Remember you got the double jumps.
Oh, yeah.
Double jump out of trouble.
Quantity.
Uh, oh.
Damn.
Quantity.
Maybe, you know, they say the more the merrier.
Oh, oh, oh, epic bloody dove!
What would they say?
They say size over matter.
There's something about size.
Yeah, I gotta go find the portal.
Everybody won't leave me alone.
I think I'll do my aura again.
It's been a minute.
Let's follow the winds of fate.
The winds say...
Oh, geez.
Open the chest.
Evasion.
What's this thing?
Oh, that's the boombox.
Thank you for a year or two days, Minto.
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Sorry, we have no bananas because Minto bought them all.
going into the stores and i'm scooping up as many bananas as
i can looking like a mad woman just being like give me all
that you got
one or two one or three gain 10 damage to elites i think
i'll go for one
the wind is not blowing i think oh my Should I get you
already?
Yeah.
Let's go.
I am going to a different location.
The winds are blowing this way.
I think?
Actually, are they blowing the other way?
Wait, were they blowing behind me?
Look!
The winds are blowing.
Opening the chest, health.
Yes, we shall open some more chests.
Now that I'm getting...
I'm getting bucks, baby.
Zawarudo!
More cheese.
More...
Cheese can stack.
I remember that too.
More bloody tone.
Banana for scale.
We'll go over banana.
Okay, I really...
Ouch!
I'm stuck on a tree!
I gotta keep an eye out.
I'm gonna go for more banana.
For the chest?
No.
Okay.
Ouch!
Holy!
A shield!
Get extra gold when taking damage.
That's not great.
I think I gotta go this way anyway.
They're just knocking stuff over.
Wait, see, this is the monkey cage that I wanted.
The golden key is right next to the monkey!
Holy cow.
Wait, he's going?
Wait, look at him go.
Wait, he's dancing.
Find and release a monkey in the forest, kill 500 enemies
while standing still.
What does he do?
What does the monkey do?
What does the monkey...
I gotta go find the...
thing so bad.
Thunder mix!
New character.
Oh!
Fun!
Okay, let's go this way.
Wrapped up in a blanket.
Wee!
That sounds so nice.
Uh oh.
I don't have time for you.
Wait, I really don't have time time for you.
Please!
Lisa!
I need to find the portal.
More ghost.
I can't stop getting ghost.
Legendary aura.
I bought the legendary aura.
More burger uh uh more more banana i
guess we'll do the power of or thorns maybe thorns maybe
power up i feel like i don't get so many of these
oh the power oh i got it though number of people with the
cheese uh i killed so with cheese.
Okay, wait, where am I going?
Okay, uh...
Guys, I'm lost.
Truly.
We've been this way before.
I haven't been this way before.
I see the wind going this way, actually.
Maybe this is the right way.
Oh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Wait!
I always knew my ghostly ocean could aura farm!
Beef fevering increased damage by 20% per 100 max HP.
Beef!
I feel like a beef just suits this guy, no?
Size.
We'll do a quantity.
Is it this way?
Please say yes.
Where the heck is this thing?
Guys, I have six seconds!
I'm not gonna make it!
Wait, but the winds are going this way for real!
No!
It's near?
It is?
I have no idea.
The winds are not turning red.
More cheese.
Is it red wind?
It's not.
It's just regular wind.
I don't think I'm gonna make it.
This is the wrong wind?
Wait, I thought you could follow the regular wind and it
would still lead you.
Oh, the white winds are just ambiance.
Ah, is that so?
Is that so?
Uh, oh, geez.
Oh, geez.
Uh, we're still looking.
Where am I?
Okay, I'm going to an area that I've never been to before.
it's all over for us everybody it's absolutely over for us
oh my god
where the heck is this thing
uh it's all over we're so bad it's all over
I can't even see
I like how you guys were still trying to direct me on what
thing to choose when literally it it was weird weird weird i
got some achievements though that was great
yeah we did lots of quests monkey monkey i do outside edge
of map then inside you will find it 100 of the times oh
really okay okay Good job.
Die 10 times.
I got the curse doll.
Let's see.
Uh, oh, here.
Nice.
Yeah!
Shop.
Carry more weapon.
Wait, I have such little money.
Wait.
A mug.
Buy poison flask.
Oh, buy the banana ring.
Uh-oh, the cursed doll.
Slot is worth it.
I thought that could be a monkey.
Get the weapon slot first.
But I want to be a monkey.
I want to be a monkey.
Monkey later.
Yes, dad.
I'll be a monkey later.
What other weapons are we on the hook?
Idol juice.
Wait, I want to try the cursed doll.
All right, let's keep going.
What did it say?
I think I'm gonna bunk.
It throw out his default banana rang.
Climb up walls!
That's huge.
Mega Chad, here we go.
Alright, this time do the outside.
Where does it put us in?
Find the boss portal.
Yes sir.
24% damage.
You already see the red winds?
Death seal.
Nice.
Flamewalker.
Wait, have I gotten that before?
Let's just do my aura.
Three, yeah.
Nice.
Some more gold.
I'll take it.
Wait, you guys saw the red wings already.
Oh, I see it too.
I see it too.
This way.
Something sparkling.
Oh, it's my money.
Oh, I don't have enough money.
More size.
This shows...
Wow.
It's like kind of far from where we spawned.
But the red winds are already showing, which makes me think
we were so far away.
Oh, it's right here!
Bob.
I got him.
Alcha, please stop.
Power gloves.
Present chance upon hitting an enemy to create a giant
blast.
What is my luck this time?
an enemy dealing 30 percent of their max hp every second
crazy good start wait unstable transfusion 31 stack of blood
mark everybody's saying one i'm trusting you all i'm
trusting you all what a start we already have the location i
just gotta not die i just gotta not screw it up Oh, oh, rare
size.
More size.
I want the banana ring, though, again.
You know?
Wait, there's a chest over here.
I'll get a banana when it comes back, guys.
We'll get a banana, don't worry.
I kind of want to up my movement speed.
You need weapons.
I do need weapons.
You're right.
Maybe I refresh.
Well, we already have the size toad.
There's a red arrow in the mini-map behind chat that shows
the direction of the portal.
There is.
Damage, though.
Yeah, we're pretty slow.
That's my concern.
It's hard for me to dodge the bosses.
That's why I kind of wanted the agility.
Oh, when you're close enough.
The arrow is only after you find it.
Okay, okay, thank you.
Don't need to dodge if you kill them off-screen.
Alright, we'll go for size then.
A backpack!
One projectile count for all weapons.
Alright, banana.
Banana come home.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
This is not good.
I think there was a heart.
There was like some heart.
over here.
Oh wait, don't kill me.
I could do bone instead of banana.
Bone is also projectile, so we'll go with the bone.
Bone is weaker, but can bounce.
I see, I see.
I mean, if we get banana, that's great too.
Honestly.
We could get both, right?
Spore.
Quantity tone.
I see the heart.
Over there.
I see it.
Attack speed.
Or jump height.
Both is good.
Attack speed.
Yeah, because we had the three slots.
Oh yeah, because of bone?
With bone, it's great, no.
Wait, there's a...
Wait, did I get this golden one already?
Yes, I did.
Chunkin, chunkus, chunkus again.
Chunkus is bad.
You evil.
You were evil.
You're trying to get me, huh?
Us.
Okay!
We'll do more bone.
Why is there a crown all the way up there?
Me when I say I'm six feet?
There's another heart down there.
Okay, I knew there was more.
Oh my goodness!
Back up!
Social distance.
Six feet versus 511.
Phantom, we all scream in unison.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Where can I...
We'll do the saw.
Oh, kill 15,000 goblins.
Good job, team.
Yeah, we're gonna aim for the quantity.
The quantity tone.
So...
6% life still.
Good goblin slay.
Thank you.
This run started out so strong, I don't want to...
Oh, I see the...
Oh, lightning's there.
I see the air...
Wait.
I see it on the mini map.
Let's go.
Sa!
Wait!
No, dang it!
We have size!
But we want more size!
Dang it.
Oh, I thought it was the...
I thought it was epic quantity.
be like, no stinking way.
That's craziness.
Still good, though.
Still good.
Oh, can we cash money?
Absolutely.
Oh, bugs.
Quantity!
Get them all!
Bigger is So true.
And projectile speed!
Wait, but lock.
You guys say lock.
Feeling lucky.
I'm one other stinking ghost.
Why do I get ghost so right?
I think the game is trying to tell me something.
I wonder.
Yeah, I wonder too.
I don't want to go too far off, but...
I think this is going to be super legendary.
Never mind.
Attack speed.
But one extra jump.
Because the game knows I'm a ghost.
Extra jump.
Jump is handy even here.
Okay.
I'll trust you.
Oh, this is another thing.
I thought this was a shady man.
Another more extra jump.
I could have gone with evasion actually, but...
So how many do I have now?
Holy!
Kind of suck.
Guys!
Rare aura!
Sorry, I keep getting aura.
My bad.
Rare bone.
Banana.
Sorry, I made all the, I made executive decisions.
I made some executive decisions.
I hope they were okay.
Copy machine for key?
For key?
Wait, where did it go?
Oh, there it is.
Thank you.
For the key?
Oh, well.
Thank you.
Shall we?
Oh, there's a shady man.
Executive Vingy.
Don't you dare.
Don't you dare leave.
Guys, I think we're...
Oh, you can reuse them.
I did not know this.
More armor.
I shall go reuse it.
Give me a second.
Moldy cheese!
Wait.
Curse doll or moldy cheese?
The cheese is goaded.
Copy the cheese.
Oh, you're right.
That's what I've done before in the past.
I've gotten the cheese and I've copied it.
Beep.
Copy the cheese.
Holy hell.
Don't come close to me.
That guy just came walking like you knew me you all right
shall we head back maybe hmm let's do more quantity
oh the bonks have been mega we're i think we're doing pretty
well oh phantom shroud i'm late i've been unwell today no
glitter i'll be feeling okay i'll be feeling okay oh i do
have three jumps i can just jump up there huh after evading
deal two-time damage next attack oh my god huge
more three what is that oh hell yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
activate it now or once i kill this guy okay oh shoot oh
shoot another i nuked him maybe i don't need we'll see let's
just let's just let's just try i'm nervous though
here we go where is it oh there it is oh ouch he's in the
trees what a cheater
we are winning he is the trees let's go it's a
more projectile I think it'll be good to be honest
even more cheese stop it you're too kind you're too kind
more projectile please let's do the size this Oh, rare bow.
Let's do a bone because of the damage, right?
It's ours.
Final swarm.
Should I just try and last?
Or should I portal right away?
Hold.
Boss farming?
We could like go for a minute.
you know
find a magnet easier said than done maybe maybe somebody
will drop one alright never mind I'm going in I'm going in
I'm going in I'm going in I'm going in ouch ouch wait how do
I oh wait that was close
and then I see a shady guy.
What wares do you have?
Oh my gosh, they give it the super jet.
More free, more, or more banana!
Beefy.
Maybe the beef.
Well, I don't think my health is.
Reflect any incoming damage back to the attacker and gain a
short invulnerability.
One or three.
Mirror could save your life.
I know.
I think I'll go with the...
beefy my health needs to be a hundred though we need to we
need to heal
spike what's my armor at anyway nine percent okay
so we must find the boss portal once again
the challenge oh there was a challenge wasn't there One?
Okay, thank you guys.
I didn't know which one to do.
Woohoo!
I'll take- I don't think I've gotten one for free though.
I think I'm getting scammed.
A little bit.
Slurp cloves cast blood magic upon hitting an enemy?
Oh, it was free!
Excuse me.
Oh my god.
Oh my goodness.
It's been a second since we've had the flex like that.
Oh, nice.
Oh wait, my health is full.
Oh, I would like...
Evasion is good too, though.
Oh, wow, another raid.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Train all.
Thank you so much.
We're bonkin today.
Was that a kiss?
Thank you so much for the...
Oh no, it was Eam.
Thank you so much for the podcast.
Thank you.
Went so fast.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Let's see.
Maybe with a shield.
Yeah, lots of raids today.
Glitch face, thank you.
Home now.
I've better been listening.
Welcome home.
Let's see.
Let me take a sip of water.
Nah, well, thank you so much for the fun.
Give it to her.
Phil, thank you.
Shield is good.
Yeah, you're right.
Honestly, I need it.
I need it too.
Electric plug.
Upon taking damage, send out an electric shaw.
There I go, thank you.
Where are we going now?
Maybe I want to go this way then.
I wish I weren't so slow.
You know?
What the heck is that?
Wait, there's a magnet!
Boss curse.
Ah!
Too busy aura farming to go fast.
I have to go slow so everyone can take it in, you know?
Your screams peeking the mic are so good tonight.
Oh, I'm sorry!
Ow, ow, ow, ow!
I think I'm done for.
Ouch.
Oh no, I lost.
I need the life steal.
Ouch.
I need to be 100 so that my B-3 ring does more damage.
It adds to the vibe.
More cheese, please.
Alright.
We're gonna go check over here for the boss port.
Which I don't see.
Ouch.
I do not see it.
More banana rhyme.
Oh my god.
That would have been bad.
Holy cow.
right into them.
That was pretty bad.
Look at this guy acting like he doesn't care.
Ouch!
I didn't even get to find the portal.
I didn't even get to find it.
Cliffs are dangerous.
That one was crazy.
that was way that was way bigger of a drop than i thought it
would be but we got a new character i have to unlock him
though don't i the ogre bye monkey okay
no one knows where he got his shades no one asks tip for
when you have multiple projectile weapons quantity is almost
always goaded but it applies to all of the weapons even if
there are others with better color oh i see yeah wait like
no i get that it applies to all the weapons i like quant i
guess more quantity would have been better huh let's try our
monkey pal monkey monkey monkey i'm even i'm even gonna go
tier two with him because i know i believe in the banana
ring I believe in banana rang I believe in banana rang Yeah
Time to cook Is that what it just said?
Uh oh You can't tell me that I will I will think of Breaking
Bad What is This one It's a legendary
That's legendary It's gold It makes me want to press it Is
legendary better than epic?
Two for the risk reward.
It is dangerous, isn't it?
Two equals more chests.
It's kind of scary early on.
Plus one projectile count.
I love projectiles!
Wow!
This guy can...
Holy...
This guy can jump.
I need...
More.
We'll just do more, but not a rang, man.
Ouch!
Leave me alone!
Mm-mm.
Well, I guess this is nice because I'm losing health.
I need some more weapons, please.
I need the quantities of weapons, please.
Knockback.
Mm-mm.
Wait, this is kind of awesome.
We go so fast.
Oh no.
Ouch, I ran right into him.
This must be the strat.
Mawai to the south.
Did I miss him?
Mawai.
Oh, now you can...
I don't see it.
Oh, I see.
Wait, that's not a Malai.
This is a boss curse.
Quantity!
Not Malai.
I might have gotten one, guys.
Boss get up ahead.
Oh, you saw the red wind?
Ex-pe...
Oh, I see it!
Ouch!
Wait, I see Moai.
I see one.
I see Moai.
Moai Insights.
I do need damage, huh?
Yeah.
Increase damage!
exactly what I needed.
Let's start opening some chests.
Another burger!
Why do you hate me?
You think I'm American and that game knows that like you are
so American.
Eat your burgers, Apollo.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay, I probably should be looking where I'm going, huh?
I wish I could get some health though.
I wish I could get some health.
Do you think a size would be good?
Two?
Oh yeah, probably actually, because then we can get more
projectile for this one.
Oh, geez, oh, geez, oh, geez.
Oh, this one's tough.
Wait.
Yeah, I know I need another weapon.
I know, I know.
We'll do shield, okay, yeah.
Big... wait, that's not a big skill.
He's just climbing on top of people.
Ouch!
Okay, we retry.
It was my first time playing with Monkey.
I gotta get used to him a little bit.
Ah.
That's okay.
We try again.
It's also tier two.
Yeah.
We got this.
Maybe we'll get some luckier bros this time.
Oh, I see Mawai.
I see Mawai.
Let's go get him.
I keep forgetting I can climb the walls.
It's kind of huge.
Wait, does that tomb Mawai?
No way.
And a chest over here.
What the heck?
Attack speed.
I wonder if the fire staff would be good because we're going
to focus on projectile.
Oh, it's a legendary shady guy!
Three or refresh?
Okay, good.
Oh, I think luck would be better here, huh?
Wouldn't it be?
But then two extra charge strines for future stages.
I think the luck would be better.
Oh, it is a legendary guy!
Oh, one projectile count!
for all weapons.
Okay, let's see what we got.
A spice, a meatball.
Oh, you guys were saying...
Yeah, nice.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
We will be aiming to increase projectiles after all.
Yeah, exactly.
Plus one chance to proc.
Unhit?
Proc?
Proc.
Giant fork.
Okay.
You can eat so much spaghetti.
Proc equals take effect.
Attacks have 25% chance to explode.
Oh, yeah, spicy meatball is like a crowd control, isn't it?
Crits have a 14% chance to be...
Okay, well, we can't...
We'll come back to this, obviously.
Can't even do anything with it right now.
Mini monkey.
That was Windows.
Got a med kit.
Thank you very much.
I think I'll save up for the bomb.
I'll save up.
Oh, no stinking way.
Wait, but I do have to go find the...
Jeez!
I have to go find the...
Extra gold when taking damage.
Good guy.
Look at his face.
He's chased me.
Four.
Eight together strong.
Life steals good time, isn't it?
Yeah, it was one or three, so we'll go with the three.
And then we'll aim for the quantity.
So, we should have ourselves a nice little setup.
I keep forgetting I can climb up the walls.
Hard with only two tomes.
Yeah, I think...
Well, I mean, I don't think I've even unlocked the ability
to do more, so.
Oh!
Banana ray!
Oh, wait, the quantity!
Ah!
Okay.
That's kind of unfortunate.
I guess we gotta go for quantity.
Chunkers.
I think I'm gonna refresh this.
Two or three?
I think I'm gonna refresh.
Does does projectile count for axe?
The revolver?
It does.
Fires multiple bullets.
Don't you have to aim with the revolver though?
Isn't it tough to use?
You guys are just saying revolver because of Acelot.
Oh wait, you don't have to aim.
It's auto.
Revolver has crits.
But would it also have more?
Six shots.
Does it turn into more?
You can try if you want.
Axe over revolver.
I feel like axe is great for people or for like when I get
kind of cornered, you know?
Axe is better because size tome.
I didn't get the size tome.
I got the quantity tome.
A little different.
Or do you mean the quantity?
If I don't get this weapon, what kind of weapon do you guys
suggest I should aim for?
This SAA is a soldier's...
Wait, it is a soldier's weapon of choice.
Bone or Lightning Staff.
Okay, okay.
Two.
Thank you.
Why are you reading this?
Gasp, are you obsessed with us?
I think you're obsessed with me.
Of course I'm going to read you.
Thank you, JV.
If you want to learn the game build route on whatever you
think is fun.
Let's go for the bloody tome and I'll aim for bone then.
Honestly, I would want the bone.
I'm not going to lie.
I don't want the electricity.
because...
Because...
I fear that we already have this fire staff, you know what I
mean?
I don't want something so similar.
Oh.
Projectile, okay.
Let's still go with the bloody tomb.
I'm gonna go with the golden...
Oh, draw- ouch!
We're at the edge.
Yeah.
We're going around.
Trying to find the, uh...
Oh, I got a complete...
30 quests, but I don't know what I did.
About time for the bomb.
Oh, you're right!
Um...
Wait, there's another shady guy over here.
What do you have?
Unstable transfusion.
Wait, this one's pretty good, no?
nice
oh credit card credit card I guess would have been good for
can I climb down walls no wait I think I see the red winds
we have found I'm gonna get this challenge real quick and
then we'll go uh
We'll both buy from the guy.
Ouch, ouch.
Did I do it?
Swarming, honey.
I don't feel like I have enough for a swarm right now.
No!
I guess we gotta go with the lightning.
Oh, it dropped it.
Nice.
That was not what I wanted, though.
Oh geez, I look at that though.
I'm so mad!
At least we can cheese it.
Wanted I used it.
There was a microwave, was there?
What do I do with that?
banana rang or the...
Yeah, banana rang?
Okay.
Attack speed.
Oh, wait, there was luck!
Another epic banana rang!
Holy cow!
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
Microwave.
Multiply cheese.
Multiply.
The clover.
I don't know if they actually stack.
Multiply trees.
Oh, it does stack.
Great.
Where was that guy?
Oh, please, excuse me.
Minto Mega Bonk Monkey Monday.
Yippee!
Yeah.
Where was he?
Uh...
Oh.
I didn't use the menu.
Oh, I do see the map.
Okay, if I need a second to...
Okay, so we're here.
Does it not show?
Is it him?
It was close.
Actually, I have no idea.
It doesn't...
It doesn't show up on the map.
Or if he does, I don't know what is...
I think he was south.
Dude.
Where am I?
my head.
I'm heading east.
Oh, wait.
I think this is him.
I think that's our guy.
I think I found him.
Yes.
Okay.
That, I think we...
I think we need the spicy meatball.
It's all pretty good, right?
I don't know.
1 or 3 I think I don't understand So one chance to So a hit
effect would be like Like the cheese
One is meta but 3 works better for T2 Oh really Okay okay
Okay Cheese I have the transfusion The blitch is the blood
mark.
Plus one chance.
Like rolling with advantage in D&D.
See.
But what does the...
Wait, okay, hold on.
I'm guessing it's over on this side.
Three is funny boom though.
I kind of want to see what three looks like, you know.
Oh, plus one roll.
Ah, okay, okay.
But watching when I get home from work, it always makes me
laugh as well.
Keep it silly, cute, and amazing.
See ya, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ah, it's a burger.
Burger, burger.
Alright.
I think we got...
We got ourselves, not the ideal setup, but we got ourselves
a nice little thing going.
Holy cow, you're ginormous.
Epic quantity tome!
Lay epic quantity tome.
I think I should probably start leveling up my other staff,
so ah.
Big git.
for real.
Holy cow.
I want to get this chest here.
Blood magic.
Damaging.
Oh.
No, don't leave me.
Yes.
We could kill him even from so far away.
That's crazy, guys.
Yeah, we do need some healing, right?
I do.
I see a heart over there.
Where was it?
Oh, that was kind of lame.
He just started like, he wasn't even sliding, he just
started sitting.
Lifesteal!
Okay.
I'm trying to, wait, where was it again?
This way.
I don't want to do this real quick.
I'm just dragging his butt.
size I thought about the other one but I changed my mind oh
I see it
you're cooking something now I want to do the quantity tone
but I feel like our damage needs to you know 3 like 1 or 3
start heading to the portal I am oh wait what does he have
what do you have mister
unstable transfusion we can get that again we can have a
stack where was it oh this way sorry I don't have time I
gotta go I gotta go I think it's right here yeah
oh wait oh no we have Chunky's end of Lil and the bark.
Rare quantity tome.
Yay, key!
We're okay.
I just keep upping my quantity tome.
Oh,
epic fire stab.
Ghost.
Oh, even more!
When it's, like, such a pretty color, I just want to, you
know...
Hold on, I'm going to open this real quick.
Let's go!
I'm leaving.
I think this is my first time!
Here!
You think I can get that?
Oh!
Bob!
Thank you, Bob.
Should I summon the challenge?
I think so.
Oh, not now.
Totally bananas.
Holy bananas.
Yeah, it's good to do it before, like, uh...
Yeah, before, like, so many enemies started spawning in,
right?
A campfire!
Aww.
I see a guy up here, too.
Let's see what he's got.
What do you have, sir?
Oh!
I can't tell if I want Jim sauce or feathers.
Jump out of problems.
A monkey's specialty.
Okay, be careful of clips.
This is... I'm so high up!
Oh, I got my little campfire.
going wait that's too cute i can hear it oh it's asmr attack
speed would be better wait projectile speed or attack speed
would be better attack speed maybe okay where am i let's
start let's start covering the edges right
oh only i thought i said 2000.
we're gonna end up just acquiring every item at this point
I'm gonna start leveling on my other weapons a bit.
Or just...
Need some movement speed, you know.
Plus 20% damage at the cost of minus 5% max HP.
It's worth it?
It is?
Okay.
Why?
I think
the key It was like minus 7 HP That's like a make or break
situation Sometimes
Whoa, Chungus Wait, Chungus, hold on I gotta do a deal
Cheese Wait, charge shrines He has 7.5% increased rewards
Increased damage by 2.5 percent when opening a chest oh wait
that's kind of good no i have five cheeses let's go with
this and
then i'll open this two is good earlier but yeah no joe
no i just forgot him
okay we're making our way through the ouch ouch ouch i know
we need more movement speed like crazy but now i'll just
start oh wait i'm gonna run out of money i'm gonna start
running out of money here just jump you're so right also i
can climb i see the my why
come here buddy epic bob Does Bob stack or money is meant to
be spent So true Double Bob
Oh, movement speed Unintentionally The damage More damage,
please
Let me know guys Let me know if you guys start seeing Uh Red
winds, right?
Is this a swarm?
Why is this so craziness?
Holy cow!
I saw the gold chest.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying.
I don't know if I'll get through it.
This is a swarm.
Having the bomb here is really nice.
get that money.
Increase match HP.
Okay.
Another one.
Oh, I see the red winds!
I saw red winds.
Nice jumps.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Shady man.
You're making so much money more.
Hmm.
We don't have the gloves.
But then also the key.
Yeah, also the key.
They are going...
I'm not quite sure.
I found it.
I found you.
Oh, oh, jeez.
Oh, hold on, hold on.
Oh, my gosh.
My mic almost just fell.
Okay.
Whew.
All right.
One second.
Let me actually move it a little.
Hold on.
Oh, hardware jump scare.
Yeah, I know, right?
Okay.
Sorry about that.
Resume.
That took me out.
Cook me out of my concentration, though.
Shoot.
Oh, no.
I meant to break the pot.
You got this?
Okay.
Thank you, guys.
My bad.
It's the Chad Bark.
Oh, shoot.
I ran right into him.
shoot
he's climbing up the trees again hello
come on wait I can't tell if you got me dying
slowly but surely
I want to make it to the next round oh no no no No, no, no!
Jump out!
Swarm!
This is really bad timing.
Wait, oh jeez, oh jeez, oh jeez.
Okay, we're escaping a little too much maybe.
Oh!
I did it!
Oh, I did it!
I did it.
Holy cow!
Hmm.
Uh...
I guess I needed all that time, huh?
It was like, what, four minutes or something?
Or...
I'm actually gonna do my bloody tone.
Wait!
What are you?
Where'd you come from?
Oh!
Epic!
Till 50% more damage while airborne.
Wait!
I jump a lot.
Wait, Scarf might be so good, you guys.
Right?
Or...
Two or three, I think.
Hmm.
Two is 40% all the time.
Okay, that's fair.
That's so true.
You're right.
I need this.
Thank you.
And then...
I need that.
I need this.
Wait, why isn't my portal open?
Oh, man.
Okay.
Oh, it's because I'm only in tier 2, huh?
I understand now.
I understand.
I remember that's how the game works.
I remember.
Run up the outside wall?
Okay.
That's so funny actually.
I'm gonna go run up the outside.
Is that a...
What is this?
Luck tone.
Come running.
Where am I going?
I think I hit an invisible wall.
I think I'm an invisible wall.
Ape escape.
We are free.
Holy cow.
I'm gonna make the world record.
I'm gonna make the world record, everybody.
I'll make my mom proud.
I didn't run.
Avoid fall damage 10 times when something something.
Almost two minutes.
That was craziness.
Oh, I made it into the 30,000s.
Hmm.
Avoid taking fall damage ten times by hugging walls.
Lectome.
0.01 chance to drop when killing an enemy.
Oh.
Oh, nice!
We got something really lucky!
Complete Forest Tier 2.
We got Robinette.
Wait.
Is that a lady?
Check the blood mark.
What does that mean?
Luck Tome is one of the best highly recommended.
I bet.
Holy yeah, it was a great run!
1.3 million damage.
Oh, skip level up offers.
Oh, okay.
That's what we unlocked there.
We got a lot.
Whoa!
Bloody ocean.
So sorry if you've already answered this question.
What?
Thank you so much for the August.
But first of all, what keeps you motivated to keep
streaming?
I'm trying to write my own story, but I struggle with
getting the motivation to continue writing.
Do you have any tips on getting motivation?
Oh, is that the question you said you were going to ask?
Bloodmark is reverse poison.
It's the dark red bar that builds from the left.
The moment boss, mob, HP touches the bloodmark.
Instant down.
Yes?
Oh, what the heck?
You could have asked this way earlier.
Listen to Virgil.
I think...
I think everybody's motivations are going to be kind of
different, though, no?
Like...
Um, for me, for me, I, uh, how do I say, I just get a lot
of, I think, how do you say, if you get, um,
satisfaction isn't the right, isn't the word that I'm trying
to think of, but I think it's the closest thing.
Like a sense of fulfillment, right?
A sense of fulfillment out of doing it.
I mean, that's what, how I feel when I stream, you know,
when I see people's comments that say that it was so funny
that they like watching me when they're working or after
work and things like that, you know, that always motivates
me so much.
uh the high of achieving something right like you know i
think for riding it might be a little different but if you
you know because riders block is always a thing and not to
say that i don't get burnt out as well but anyone can get
burnt out of whatever they do even if it's something that
they love so much but with riding i think the fulfillment of
being closer to the end of your story is always probably a
really cool feeling in my opinion if you're like I'm I'm a
couple words I'm a couple chapters closer to the conclusion
of the story I'm trying to tell I think that's really you
know I think being able to conjure a story from your brain
is really amazing I'm not good with words I'm not good with
expressing myself and uh you know Sometimes people say I'm
creative, but I often have very many creative blocks.
I always want to do creative streams, and it's either one
thing that it's like, it's either creative block in like
what kind of stream I want to do, or it is a skill issue in
that I do not have the skills to implement said type of
stream that I want to do, or if it's something that I...
need a lot of people for that can be a issue for me as well
but yeah you know
matara the highlight of my career is minecraft part 21 yeah
but i know she's kidding around with that but for some
people that's like your comfort you know for some people
they love that consistency some people really need that some
people need someone to just be there to be like everything
sucks my day was bad my food was spoiled I I I I hit every
red light but you know what I can fall back on is Minto
playing Minecraft part 21 because that is the one thing that
I'm looking forward to so I know it's like memed on I know
it's memed on to do that kind of stuff but honestly it's
like so necessary at the same time part 21 was the best one
um yeah when i did that and then i and then i yeah it was
cool thank you so much for answering you and i booze of
course thank you so much for the aquasupa i really
appreciate it family guy funny moments number 54.
i have a streamer that I watch and he streams Phasmophobia
every Monday.
And it's just kind of like, yeah.
Ah, it's Monday.
It's Phasm Monday.
Ah, he's doing his, he's doing the thing again.
I'm sick with cold but watching it makes me feel so much
better.
Feel better, Brian.
Feel better.
Dutch boy Phasmo.
I love Inzu.
He's my comfort streamer.
too thank you star thank you star john thank you wait hold
on it's so hard i don't have like my normal setup so it's
hard to read the stream labs it's hard to read the donos but
thank you for seeing me at we've gone thank you
we love him so my comfort streamer Derma watching
infomercials is always my comfort.
Shall we try another round?
Oh, wait.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho, wait.
We got the unlocks.
Is Robinette good?
Does she use the bow and arrow?
I remember not liking it, though.
Let's unlock the luck tone because that sounds insane.
We got gold in sneakers.
I want to get some more.
Are these epics?
No.
These are the...
I never liked her myself.
She was top tier before gold nerf.
She's men unless you're playing for endgame.
Once upon a time I watched someone stream Minecraft in the
middle of the day and that got me to start playing
Minecraft.
Playing Minecraft in the middle of the day.
middle of the day is the best I think let's get the idle
juice the longer you stand still the more damage you do max
100% damage and let's get the golden sneakers earn money by
moving around
I'm always moving I think I want to know how to get some
more ladies, you know?
I need a slutty rocket.
I need a rocket that's gonna make me yearn and cry as soon
as I set eyes upon her.
Kill 2,000 enemies using poison damage.
We've almost got this toxic barrel.
We're at fifth, almost don't we all
so true let's see use shrine of suck eight times we might be
we might be able to get this one actually I imagine it's a
tomb oh it's attraction tomb the tomb of attraction I
imagine it will make our our suck easier but we're also
almost to a tome slot so we just need to use the shrop the
shrop sh
we just need to use we need to get this quest and then we
can get another tome slot
I will
look at this guy I thought he was wearing glasses he kind of
looked like a nerd in like in this little preview gain 1.5%
damage per level shrock shoots arrows at pierces enemies
look at her though she's so cute honey I shrock I boost use
your words Minto I'm sorry is one half of your face droopy I
just look like this
Gain 1% gold per level Also increase damage Slightly by
total gold in inventory Should we try her?
Let's try Let's try Let's try Challenges Die upon taking any
damage Or touching an enemy Wait what?
Oh shit kill all bosses what the fuck two what no i don't
want no i don't want a challenge click tears wait i'm scared
to play on tier three with her well i guess we'll figure it
out
oh i like this one i like this one a lot
I think I saw a Malai down there.
Let's get the experience.
Because we'll give him lots of gold.
That is not a Malai.
But that's okay.
You need experience for tier 3.
This is a whole new world for me, guys.
I need your help.
Luck.
Oh my god, this is kind of terrible though.
She's so slow.
Oops, I didn't mean to do that.
But that works?
Experience?
I'm like, do I get a new weapon?
No bow?
D2 projectile for now.
We can do that still.
Two or three.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, this is the Shrine of Sokka!
This is what we were looking for.
Wait, it's pointing me in the direction?
It's pointing me in the direction of something.
Did I find it?
I'm a little confused, but...
Ouch.
Oh, it was a free chest!
Oh, I did it!
did see it.
I didn't even know at all.
What was the precision dome again?
Oh, the crit.
I think...
I think the fire staff.
I think we want to have a second weapon.
We will do once again.
Oh, I do see it.
You're right.
Okay, great.
And there's a free chest down there that I missed.
Not bad.
Ouch!
Only gamers pick this one.
We'll do the power up.
Two?
Okay.
I think I don't want to make it more difficult.
I'm a little scared.
Refresh.
Quantity Tom
Trust everybody, always trust
Locks incoming attacks and sends out a shock wave I haven't
tried that one I feel though bone probably Or Aegis really
Both are good Okay I haven't tried it before so I'm curious
how it works extra jump
above scales with quantity no stinking way it does actually
that's kind of insane alright so I see the portal there
let's go explore around here
check dog out those war shields I see a shady man Oh, she
like Did a little clip
Oh, she flipped Oh, what you got, mister Oh,
cool Five steps back for each us Okay, I'll grab it
Damage One this early is a good point What the hell is Oh,
is that boulder rolling?
I see it.
Thank you, everybody.
More luck.
I kind of wish I went for damage, but that's okay.
The boulder's just rolling around.
Luckily we're pretty fast, so...
Projectile of.
Try to pick up about 30 to 30% life still.
Oh, okay.
She's almost dead.
Please.
Now she's dead.
Oh, legendary!
Wait, I don't have... I can't afford it.
Wait, that was the wrong one.
There we go.
Let me get my stinking.
Nice!
Get extra gold when taking damage.
And we have a shield here.
This one's tough.
I want the evasion, but also the movement speed.
We're pretty fast though, so we'll go with the lifesteal.
Oh.
XP.
Swarm incoming!
Wait, where did my Aegis shield go?
Why is it only...
Ouch, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, is it...
It's got a regen after I take hits.
Oh, I see how it works.
I see now.
It do come back, yeah.
Quantity.
I see how it works.
Let's keep looking around.
Exploring the map!
Attack speed increases shield regen.
No way!
Okay, good to know.
Let's keep doing XP.
Early on XP.
I missed a free chest.
I'm so bad about that.
Thank you guys.
Holy cow, look at how many...
There's...
Holy cow!
Wait, I don't think I can get that though.
I was gonna try and get the lightning bolt.
We could circle back.
Maybe.
There it is, I see it.
I'm gonna do my fire stab since we have nothing on it right
now.
It's literally level one.
XP.
They are dying fast, they are, aren't they?
We're doing a good job, maybe?
Again!
Quantitation.
and strong.
For real!
Oh, quantity!
Hmm.
Flowers there.
Over this way?
Over yonder.
Wait.
The suck!
Suck!
Nice.
It's a free chest still by the shrine from earlier.
Wait, really?
Quantity.
More quantity.
I think I'm going to do my bow, though.
Because I also had projectile up.
And staff.
Finally got a job as a graveyard shift dispatcher.
Thanks for the, thanks for the ace, your, wait, ace your
interview, baby, here I go and all the motivation says,
Congratulations!
Let's go!
Congrats!
Congratulations!
Should I do fire stuff or ball?
What do you guys think?
Or, I mean, I guess it's two.
Fire?
One for sure?
Be careful.
Quantity.
More, more, more.
I want attack speed.
All right, where am I going?
Quantity?
Two mover.
One quantity.
I know.
But also, I want to get some more damage.
You have to...
Oh, my.
You have to upgrade your stuff a lot.
Eventually.
You know?
Holy cow, that guy came charging at me.
Size.
Size or evasion be better here though?
Size maybe?
Actually size would affect my shields too, right?
Oh look at them, look they're so covered, I'm covered.
Swarm incoming.
Fireball and shields.
Yeah, yeah.
Um, maybe I guess knock.
Pickup range, really?
You guys think that?
Knock back though.
Pickup range is so useful.
I always want to get it.
Because I'm lazy.
I don't like it.
We're gonna get this Moai.
We're gonna get the Moai and then we're gonna go get the
boss maybe.
8% chance upon hitting an enemy to create a giant black.
probably the power gloves
epic bow wait the crit damage goes crazy holy oh my god
let's go back
wait did I just see a microwave I don't have any cheese time
to go crit build what could maybe the maybe i could get yeah
i could use more keys
we'll do keys
oh i'm gonna do the one last one luck a ball
even more luck
Yeah, cookies.
Oh, Chunkus.
Chunkus is big.
Excuse me.
Can't walk up the dang hill now.
Leave me alone, Chunkus.
It stole a key!
Wait, what do you mean I lost a key?
Wait, how?
What happened?
I know of only we had cheese.
The key was going to go, though.
Wait, how's that?
Oh, it consumes another item.
Well, it uses a thing to give a thing.
Wait, I didn't realize.
Oh, we got the cursed doll.
Wait, that's pretty good, though.
Alright, I'm this away.
We
got...
Where is he?
Oh, there we go.
So we had chad bark, and this is little what does what's the
third guy gonna be oh
epic fire stage you'll
see don't spoil it yeah don't spoil guys don't spoil it
feel like oh
it's a oh no i feel like i'm not doing so much damage but oh
i guess also these guys are tough
They're tougher now, huh?
Because we're on the third tier, so...
Yippee!
Oh!
I think it's good till you get that.
We'll see your DPS last time was from the cheese.
I don't think we're doing poorly, but you know.
Let's do it.
Yes, we'll get cheese eventually for a little bit.
Oh, legendary.
Okay.
Oh, quantity.
I wonder how long I can last here.
It's kind of iffy.
They're like stuck in the portal.
They're stuck through the portal.
Cheese plus banana with quantity goes hard.
It's such a good combo.
I wish I had more attack speed, honestly.
I feel like I'm really slow with my shooting my arrows.
Ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch,
ouch.
Let's just go to the next level.
Leave once you get hit.
Well, I left, so...
Look at all them dozes, right?
I see a shady man over there.
Oh, a challenge!
Let's do it.
Holy cow.
They're so fast.
Wait, they're fast coming down the hill.
They're fast coming down the hill.
The challenge, Skellies.
I have double jump?
When did I get that?
Stack XP.
Hope I'm a shrine.
Oh, there's my chest.
Come on, cheese.
Come on, cheese!
Cheese lowers!
Alright, let's see.
Let's start!
Is that an alert?
shady guy down there hiding in the corner why don't they
attack him the campfire what do you got i think are gonna go
with the damage they are both shady i try to stay away from
a shady guy
But he's like, so mysterious and cool.
Don't you want to know what he's got?
The offer?
Is that his minister?
Oh!
Giant Fork!
Crits!
Have 14% chance to become mega crits!
Gain 50% crit chance!
We are...
The crit build is real?
Maybe?
I don't even know what I'm doing.
Oh, I see it.
The portal.
Let's do more.
Oh, legendary.
Projectile count.
That's a spaghetti.
All on bow now.
Okay.
wait do i get the i think a projectile count would be better
than the jump no maybe the jump would be better than the it
does give us out of some good situations out of some tricky
you know i get it i get it i get it i'm trying to get the
cheese please
sure you already have the tome i guess that's true yeah
we're guaranteed to get more.
Uh...
We are guaranteed to get projectiles.
That's very true.
Projectile count can max out eventually.
Look at our shield.
This is kind of insane.
But we're like...
Ow.
We're doing...
Wait, how did my health go so far down?
We're doing like little tiny damage to this guy.
I'm doing teeny damage to him.
This is no good.
He gets his damage too, does it?
Not a swarm at the same time!
Leave me alone!
I can't afford it.
I'm just exploring at this point, maybe we'll find...
Oh!
Like, a Malai.
A key, I'll do the key.
I mean, XP again, we've been doing that too as well.
Let them break themselves upon your shields.
More gold means more items.
Exactly.
This guy has crazy range.
Oh, microwave.
What is this?
Oh, it's a suck.
I'll do that.
definitely copy the gold gauntlet yeah i'm saving the copy
for the cheese if i get it
oh i have to try to pay for them for it to work oh okay okay
okay okay then i will try oh my god said chips thank you but
you know i have gone to weepcon because sakura can but met a
lot of nice people with my happy hand Thank you so much for
the hug, Asufa!
I'm so glad you met people, though!
What the heck, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Let's do our bow.
Projectile speed.
It's always great to meet our bow!
Oh,
free chest.
Sorry, it's not that bad.
I'm struggling here.
We're only on...
I mean, this is tier 3, but we're only on the second level.
Oh, another one.
Oh, my God.
There's so many guys following me.
I didn't even notice they were there.
Oh, crit damage even more.
The lack of cheese is crazy.
I know.
I'm so confused.
So you get more quantity or more bow?
Made it through the merch line.
Let's do more bow.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, hello.
I might go one or two.
Maybe two because I'm taking a lot of damage, huh?
Oh, my God.
Ah!
No!
We got more, we got the new tome slot though.
Kill 4,000 enemies using fire damage.
It really does pay.
That's why these types of things, like you can always go for
the, oh, I don't have enough silver.
You can always go for the, like, you know, the builds that
you want, but it also pays to try using different things
because then you unlock more stuff.
Oh wait, I might have enough after I do this.
How much was it?
Dragonfire.
Attraction tomb.
35!
We could do a quick run.
Quick run?
I'll go in, in and out.
Monkey style.
Nice run.
Random tip with extra jumps if you fall from way.
up you can do an air jump most of the way down if you're
that's what i was doing sometimes but thank you dargo thank
you all right enough to give me some silver and then i'm
gonna go back to my vacation can
you climb down the wall yeah ouch never mind wait ouch oh
it's fine we're we're just we're just trying to get the cash
oh i should have gotten the luck tone i'm an idiot i'm an
idiot and a half give me a long
fast way for silver is silverish blue race how do i know
when i have enough to um to quit
pop left corner.
So the 35?
No, there's no way how much I will get if I quit, right?
Oh, wait.
No way.
I have it already?
Oh, I have it.
That's my total.
Oh, I have 35 altogether.
Oh, I see what you mean.
Oh, so like what I'm already holding.
I thought like I got, I thought you meant like, I gained 35
in this level.
I was like, there's no stinking way.
There's no stinking way.
Let's just see what we got going on here.
Oh, slurp?
Wait, I guess probably, no, it doesn't matter.
I'm gonna die here.
Okay.
YAHOO!
Find and activate all the boom boxes on...
Pogler purchased 40 unlocks.
With an extra despair, a single coin to my name.
Yippee!
Thank you guys for directing me once again with Mega Bunk.
Next time, we'll do Weapon Slot 2.
45 quests.
I believe we can do it.
I believe we can get 2,000 enemies with poison damage.
I believe we can get 40 quests.
I believe we can get big cash money and unlock a lot of
stuff.
So, thank you guys!
Thank you so much for MegaBunk.
I'm glad the internet held out too.
I will be streaming again tomorrow.
Uh, something.
I'll make a waiting room earlier today than I did.
Or earlier tomorrow than I did today.
Good night all.
I must retire for the night all.
Cheer no land.
Good night.
Thanks for hanging out, Minky.
Happy vacation.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the vlog.
I'm gifted.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I hope you guys get some rest as well.
Take it easy, you know.
Thanks for the stream.
Enjoy your vacation.
Thanks very much.
Thank you.
Hopefully I sound a bit better tomorrow too.
Give my voice some extra time to Resta Good to have you
back, I'm Vinky.
Thank you so much.
Dago, thank you.
Thank you for the streaming.
Don't you, the grit.
I'm so glad your day's off.
I've been awesome.
Have a good night.
You too.
Thank you so much.
Resta, pink.
Thank you.
You sound good.
Just a little tired.
I overworked it a bit.
I was like...
Okay.
Oh, tomato.
Bye-bye!
Take care everybody!
Have a good day, have a good day, have a good time zone!
I'll see you when I see you next!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
Bye-bye!